Since it's design week,
we have a VFF joining us who has a design dilemma
and she needs help with
so please welcome the lovely Robin.
(audience applauding)
Hi Drew, hi Ben, hi Erin.
Hi.
How are you?
Robin, tell us what your design dilemma is, first of all.
Of Drew, I have a bookcase that is beautiful.
It's natural wood, but look at it.
It is so boring.
I don't know how to decorate this bookcase.
I have a few books.
I have a few knickknacks.
It's tucked away in my spare bedroom.
I want to make this a centerpiece,
a prominent statement piece.
And how can I do this?
I totally see what you're talking about.
It like, it wants that joy factor.
It wants that love, it wants that touch.
Ben and Erin have an amazing idea.
I'm gonna turn it over to them.
Walk us through your DIY vinyl record bookshelves,
they're so cool.
So for music fans, this one is especially fun.
These are very, very scratched albums we founded
a thrift store, okay?
No vinyls were harmed at the making
of this bookend cap.
They're gonna be harmed.
(laughing)
I keep saying like with bookends is like,
we have bricks from houses that we've lived in, and-
Some dog statues that looks like our dog.
That looks like our dog.
So like our bookends are very personal and knickknacky.
You can make more personal bookends
and then that gives you another object on your shelf.
That's like something to tell people about,
conversation piece.
And it's super, super simple.
So this is what we're gonna make, okay?
And this is how you do it.
All right, you've gotta have very hot water.
So We have a percolator.
I'm gonna hold the record, you hold the-
I'll do the pouring.
Pour it on the record.
Okay, you pour it on the record slowly
and you start to put it down in the water.
And let it bend.
It's gonna start to melt the vinyl.
Then you use something like a cutting board
if you have it handy, and you can bend it.
So you're gonna take it then,
see it's bendy.
Oh wow.
And put it under the cutting board.
And you're gonna press it forward.
And now that's good,
it only takes a second.
That's good?
Yep and pull that away and we have a bookend.
(audience applauding)
That is so cool.
I was under full hypnosis the entire time.
That was hypnotic to watch.
Yeah, so there you go, there you go.
Now Drew, you have a tip.
I do.
I'm so excited to be collaborating with Ben and Erin Napier.
I'm having a pinch me moment.
Okay. so I think about a bookshelf,
books, it's an obvious fit.
But is there something different
that you can do with the books themselves?
So I'm gonna show you an easy way to transform a book.
Now I'm just taking scraps of fabric here.
We're putting tape on the end.
They're pre-cut they have a little bit of an angle
and almost think of it as like a wrapping job,
is that you kinda want to cut according
to the size of the gift you're wrapping
and you wanna pull it kind of taught.
And then you wanna go to the other side,
flip the pages of the book, 'cause you wanna do this
all on the edges.
And I'm gonna show you an example
of a bookshelf that I did in my entryway.
I found a magazine cover that I was really inspired by
and I sort of did my own interpretation.
Those books were my old antique books and I painted them.
So you can also paint your books
if that really speaks to you, or cover it in fabric.
Okay, so this is basically
what it's gonna end up looking like.
And I kinda thought maybe for you to go
with the records so that the beautiful book ends
that Ben and Erin made could really stand out
and not have different colors, fonts
and type treatment fighting it.
This way, the beautiful vinyl bookends stick out
and yeah, just a little greenery and flowers
and a way to really let those vinyl bookends shine
and not distract away from them.
I don't know, Robin, what do you think?
Are you?
Oh, it's amazing.
I'm a music lover, I'm an art lover,
I'm a reader and everything is affordable.
I can do it myself, so that's awesome.
Yeah.
Robin, I just wanna thank you so much
for trusting us with your design dilemma
and Ben and Erin, it has been such an honor
to have you here on this show
and I'm really excited about the new show that's coming.
It's in Wetumpka, Alabama.
Is that correct?
And it'll be coming hopefully, around this spring?
Yeah "Hometown Takeover", we did over an entire town.
Yep, it's 12 huge projects, six episodes.
It's a mini series.
It'll be different from "Hometown" in a lotta ways.
And then it's gonna have all the heart
all the design that people love.
And it's some of the most incredible people
that we have ever met, that we get to work with
on these houses.
Deserving people get beautiful things.
Yeah, it' really cool.
And then I have a new show that's on Discovery Plus
called "Hometown Ben's Workshop."
And I'm thinking that Drew needs to come.
I think so too.
Do I start running now or do I wait for the call?
I'm really excited.
I would, I'll be there in a heartbeat.
Are you kidding?
Yeah, just come this way.
We'll, you know.
We'll work it out.
Sort out the logistics later.
Okay, I'm ready.
You just say when and I'll be right there
and I can't wait for "Hometown Takeover",
which will be coming to HGTV this spring
and "Hometown Sundays" on HGTV.
There's "Hometown Ben's Workshop"
which is available to stream now on Discovery Plus,
hopefully I'll be getting to go there soon.
And speaking of takeover, you've taken over the world
and you've taken over our hearts.
I can't thank you enough for being here today.
Thank you for having us.
This is so fun, thank you.
Tell your little girl, I said hello by the way.
She's gonna be so great.
Oh, you know what. I take it back.
Tell her Gertie says hello.
Yes, yeah, Gertie.
Thank you so much.
I would love to see you guys soon.
(upbeat music)